[Music]
in aesthetic accident news submitted by
XYZ an influencer is defending her
decision to post photos of her
motorcycle accident on Instagram I like
this one I don't know this one this
one's so good we did somebody like get
hurt okay so this is next-level [ __ ] we
should like on the fling this is really
hard
oh just got hurt we know people like
that
we didn't I mean not a specific person I
think there's a lot of people that you
know this [ __ ] is the Steve Jobs 1984
Apple commercial of the influencer
medium probably promised like the one
where she smashes where she thought the
hammer through the screen like to
destroy there's gonna revolution
influences okay I want I can wait okay
so her name is Tiffany Mitchell she has
over two hundred eleven thousand
followers on Instagram she's based in
Nashville and so she shared these very
professional shots of her motorcycle
accident and a very very lengthy post so
this is the first photo in her what is
she in her carousel oh that's cute the
carousel she's hot it's like when
there's no slideshow bingo oh okay
they're called carousels um so then this
is the next one what is this real I love
this [ __ ] so really good in an accident
though wait is that a tattoo or like
hash it's a stage acts are you kidding
she ends the caption with I'm resting
and healing up my arm and her tattoo
artist may need to touch up my
wildflowers but I'm feeling so much
better and guys I am beyond grateful but
the rest of the caption she's talking
about how that was like the first photo
has her in her bike about an hour before
she got into the accident she said that
Oh photos with the photographer before
this and that but there's the first
photo to prove it but this chick like
the photographer
was still shooting away okay after like
she got into her accident no those are
staying
instead of getting help I mean that guy
was helping her I love how they had
enough time to lift the bike back up and
stage it behind in the back background
with the guy picking her up and they're
like you might get the SmartWater okay
perfect perfect is it really a brand new
label out it looks like a brand new oh
no strain on the journalists did look
into whether or not this was a brand new
with smart water and smart water said no
they don't course they're gonna say no
brand deal like they don't have any
association with her anything and so but
anyway she's she's talking about how
three years ago she lost her partner to
a motorcycle accident and in the caption
that's what's in the cabin that first
long caption that's so weird like you
know I was devastated whether or not I
was gonna get back on a bike but then
she ends up saying that but what smart
water could give her the courage
strangers came to her aid and legs
cleaned her up in the ambulance
oh but the way she got into the accident
by the way is that she she misjudged a
curvy she took it too fast and her bike
went off the road and she slid through
the grass and she hit the pavement
Oh her head was fine cuz her for help
because of her helmet but she did scrape
her left side and she was just like I
was just left an absolute shock on the
side of the road I'm so thirsty after my
motorcycle accident I just needed a
drink of water in it first in Cape I
gave me smart water guys you could take
my picture from when I had kidney stones
when I'm getting loaded in the ambulance
or when I'm like laying on I'm laying on
my back from when I had kidney stones
that I'm in Costa Rica and you put you
you could Photoshop a [ __ ] sip matcha
in my hair like this you go ahead and
you do that you can use that [ __ ] you
doing this kind of [ __ ] genius and it's
a professional photos and damn so then
this went viral in the sense that people
were like how the [ __ ] do you just share
this like and then like this is taking
it too far like these photos are too
professional they obviously look so
staged and color corrected like a
mummy's tell me this is real please tell
me she didn't roll us she's
sticking to her saying that this was
real oh by the way I got a mentioned
even in the BuzzFeed article they like
throw her under the bus a little bit cuz
then under the bike yeah I'm gonna bite
you nice um cuz she ends up saying my
mum she said I'm sad that some people
are taking it that way and then this is
article six
she adds les yeux she added before
requesting buzz foot boy not some smart
water yeah there we go
but yeah the article says before
requesting BuzzFeed news not to proceed
with writing this story as it would
quote draw negative attention but then
they still shared it and then that's how
I drew negative attention to her page on
this so she ends up posting this photo
here with their bike and then this
really really long caption I'm not gonna
read it all know the ego on these
[ __ ] influencers are just hilarious I
love it please please keep this alive
ever change then I just showed you
she's saying that she has been getting a
lot of negative reactions because of the
negative you mean realistic reactions
from people calling you out on your
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're like you're a
hater not dude we're not no one hating
people are just like do you think we're
that [ __ ] dumb that you staged a
photo shoot
she said that Busby's but BuzzFeed news
posted sensationalizing what she went
through that day and making a mockery of
the post that she shared she
sensationalized herself I feel like
she's making a mockery of like her
boyfriend that died yeah I think it's
one thing if you want to do like a
creative sort of I don't know memorial
yeah memorial are like something
creative cuz you you do take a lot of
photos like I thought maybe that's what
she was doing
mmm this is what it looked like when we
fell off the motorcycle together like if
she were to do that I would respect it
more that's still weird this is one my
friend died yeah
SmartWater just random and weird it's
[ __ ] weird because she's also
profiting off death right like of a
loved one well what if it's not even her
mom okay it is her fault but uh her
photographer was like oh this is this
some good content and he was the one
snapping away did you get that let's get
that let's get that you don't mean yeah
it could be anyone's idea on that team
they're all morons for doing it together
from the [ __ ] model that decided this
is awesome girl yeah like look dead and
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] pick you up wait we
need the motorcycle you know and then
they're staging all this stuff the
person holding the bounce board not
saying [ __ ] just like laughing or
whatever everyone's [ __ ] up you know
it's funny too that the article in my
opinion did not exaggerate or make a
mockery out of her story like they're
literally just placing the facts there I
mean they did get excerpts of the
comment section so like one comment says
you had an accident you still were
taking photos and then rolling her eyes
and another one says huh you had a
serious accident but people were there
to take stunning photos this is an
insult to people who get into accidents
put a helmet on oh because people are
really upset but she didn't even have a
helmet on no they were really upset that
she was portraying that you should move
someone and remove the helmet after
they've had an accident because that
could just do way more damage to the
person rather they had an accident she
doesn't look cute into how men the hair
just looks better like marrying out on
the ground was the BuzzFeed headline
title of the article because it doesn't
matter what they actually say it matters
about the headline cuz no one else's
that's why people don't like to read and
influencers defending her decision to
post a photo shoot of her motorcycle
accident on Instagram okay so that's not
what happened so the caption mainly
focused on her exporter like the
boyfriend I passed that was it little
she focused there was a lot of things
that were being focused so she took a
photoshoot she misjudged how she got
into the accident how she was so scared
because of like she brought in the
boyfriend because of like her connection
her emotional connection to how
traumatic that
you wanted to fall off the same way her
boyfriend did I think I'm weird
I think I'm weird and this is unpopular
opinion but I I got your back no matter
what
do it do it no I think it's a popular
opinion but like I don't see this
different yes you took it to another
level but different than whatever like a
lot of other people are it's just
[ __ ] funny you know I mean like we
know it's not unpopular we no one's
doing we know of people yeah so I'm like
why are you guys bashing on her why
their articles written when I've seen
people go like oh my dog like uh died
and then like they're like like it
looked like it was like really fake and
force yeah and then he saw the snapchat
filter yeah with like flowers but the
focal flowers still going around the
thing here that really rubbed people the
wrong way photos so when it's explained
that she was already taking pictures
like the photographer was probably
already waiting there because they did
that photo maybe seven eight times
rehearse the fall five times no not the
fall and then he just kept snapping away
and she was just like okay cool like at
least I got this content or whatever
maybe edgy a lot of people too were like
okay fine your photographer friend kept
taking photos that's [ __ ] weird like
yeah why don't you call the Oblast would
like be there for you nuts but he saw
the art happening who's live aren't
happening like like this chick is on the
nother level than the rest of us
she's an actually innovating and we're
hating you know saying she's actually
moving the medium forward and we're
being heaters so that's like one level
of like that's [ __ ] weird but then
wish she just really took it over the
top of the fact that she posted it and
like when all in water-bottle just did
it for me I mean the first layer is the
photoshoot thing right and then that one
can be kind of weird but I'm I'm just
imagining the photoshoot you say alright
stay there up can you um get over and
grab her is she's like in [ __ ] pain
she's like my arms [ __ ] broken can i
okay like everything is falling and
toppled over like an accident but the
the bottle is three did the perfect
[ __ ] laugh yeah I know you could do
this a thousand times off a motorcycle
you're not gonna get it to land in the
we should flatten the bears to begin
with it was brought in later to give her
water she did tagged the photographer
the friend and her tattoo artist saying
that he's gonna have to touch her up did
she tag SmartWater
sometimes I feel like people will do
like they'll take a picture like if I
wanted you guys to pay attention to me I
take a picture and then tag sips and all
of you so that you'd see it so maybe
she's like like fishing for brandy and
she's smart said in her that second
posts defending it she said that she's
opened up about miscarriage divorce
anxiety losing her partner with the
professional photo shoot so navigating
the freak the grief that followed so she
says that she chooses Instagram as a
tool for healing and connecting with
other humans who may be going through
this similar look wicked joke party of
one over there hey look it's funny go to
a mall I'll fake a heart attack and you
guys lay it lay Apsara pizza next to me
just a single slice just on the plate
one of the best things of this
generation it's amazing this generation
shares too goddamn much well I'm just
like this is [ __ ] amazing but I'm
just not those people that are gonna go
and comment some [ __ ] hateful [ __ ]
you're like what do you miss I just move
on but this generation watched you and
they go I want to be like geo and they
think that this is that that's what's
magic don't you understand you're part
of the problem I'm signing off here
never see me again
but addressing the whole sponsorship
thing though she did say that she makes
it very clear whenever she is working
with brands and like she's she'll never
like she didn't hide it because it
wasn't about sponsorship and she wasn't
faking it did she say she's open to
working with SmartWater in the future
cuz smart daughter does influencer stuff
I do I hope she gets out a sponsorship
from SmartWater this was very creative
I love
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]